citizens of the reject Nation it's
me Tara Erickson alongside Greg Alba
we are both a little sleepy I think I forgot
to brush my teeth but we're still gonna watch
Despicable Me 2. Despicable Me 2. I love the first
one it's so fluffy it makes me want to die I've
been saying it since I've seen that movie I just
like run around town being like it's not fluffy
no one gets it nobody gets it they just go wow
look at her maybe we should call security but I
haven't been kicked out anywhere not yet ah white
girls so guys don't forget when you're watching
this you gotta leave a like you got a comment
and they also got to bring good ring the bell
and also if you haven't become a patron you should
sorry I had to have a heart swallow there's a spit
there you should become a patron okay because
if you get over there you can watch the entire
full reaction of me and gray watching Despicable
Me 2 and you can sync up with your own copy so
you're sitting there watching a movie and we're
here too and we watched the whole thing together
that's insane insane Greg and John also cover
several shows exclusively over there with reaction
highlights and watch alongs included if there's
no more further Ado let's get into it we'll do
[Music]
the Arctic is it Alaska or is it the
North Pole secret base Kristen wig is back
so is Steve Benjamin Bratt
I didn't Russell Brand's the old scientist guy
nefario really yeah oh my God I didn't know that
yes Arc Circle okay ooh the
animation already looks improved
oh no something magnetic is happening is it aliens
nothing aliens it's not a few villain or something
or an alien no no it's a big magnet with
aliens in it take off all your metal stuff
I would be on Belton right now and not get off
the jet ski whoa yeah you can't whoa holy junk
[Music] Wilhelm scream that was a pretty cool
visual yeah that was pretty awesome did look
like an alien sucking up some humans we
don't know that it's not aliens hey at
least the porta potty survived Ah that's
like a Jurassic Park callback kind of
oh this must be a game with the girls [Music]
cool [Music] oh he's such
a sweetheart now I love it
[Music]
it already seems like they're doing cooler shots
this time around a lot more stopping shots so here
come the gallon's night to save us oh my God I
love it give me a Funko I don't want a refund
please I'm begging you you gotta
do it buddy [Music] [Laughter]
getting for a kid's birthday
hey hey it looks believable
the most magical fairy fairy
of all I am here so cute
that's so bad my house is made of candy and
sometimes I eat instead of facing my problems
okay time 4K wow all that worked for lights yeah
for 20 seconds 20 seconds of worth it [Music]
I like literally can't even stand her she's
like perfect my friend Natalie has recently
single and oh God it's you in
the future it is or me right now
oh wow whoa
I wonder there's like fan theories on what this
creature is he kind of looks like a boot that
got brought to life he looks like a rat terrier
mixed with like a porcupine ancient Lucy wild
of the AVL AVL oh sorry Advanced Aviation
something or Advanced villain like ah yeah
[Music]
he's flexible he and strong
you're gonna break his arm or his entire
body and crush his face I go get him
hurry up Steve Mark John Brian
[Music] [Laughter] [Music]
there's always those kinds of
trash cans in these movies [Music]
I'm liking the shots way
more this time around yeah
whoa and that's inventive that's fun oh boy no
[Music]
oh she is clever and capable she's intense
oh my god do they get to go underwater is
this going to turn into a boat it's
so cool this one feels more spy movie
oh it's totally a bond tribute is
this a spy leak I don't know [Music]
this is awesome this is very like Bond
mission impossible-esque yeah way more
and I think they have a much bigger
variety of a color palette this time
yeah I was just gonna say it's so bright
and like really colorful I like it I don't
I was like okay
our top secret lab disappeared
from the Arctic Circle the lab
was devoted to experiments involving
px41 no no not on the bunny no no
oh
yeah eat them up good rabbit we've had traces
of it in the paradise mall and we
believe that one if these shoppers
God he's gonna be a spy but no no leave me
Father around and they legitimate businessman I
developing a line of delicious gems and jellies
your work as a villain was kind of amazing
so if you ever want to get
back to doing something awesome
give us a call Wilde has a soft spot for grown
crew it's gonna have a love interest this time
the minions be doing that yeah [Music] exactly
what they were just doing Joy Lillian said she
was arranging a date for you she's in nut job
and I'm not going on any date and I'm scared
oh here we go again oh my
God hey Lisa I was wondering
oh poor girl kids are evil
well of how these movies
are about Gru overcoming his childhood trauma yeah
all right his jelly business
[Music]
what's about to happen
oh what was about to happen oh okay
I thought you like all deformed
[Laughter]
I miss being evil I mean don't you think there's
more of our future up than Shirley I've had an
offer of employment elsewhere what there is
no loyalty here traitor who's he gonna work
for oh maybe uh the magnet oh that or orange
jumpsuit guy is still alive Vector yeah hello
what just happened this time the aliens are here
make my day it is the cupcake
recipe I got on the internet
colors are so much more vibrant and Lush this time
around yeah not the last one looked
good too but this one's more striking
oh God that cupcake is terrifying the shark is
dope oh hello wild what are you doing oh okay
what's the point of breaking them
mine just let them fall to the grill she
loves to find cupcakes why are you here
but not me yeah but you're talented
that was a great cupcake Missy
out your cupcake
oh what does he love her
oh my God oh my God [Music]
I feel your minion you're young and
then a girl smiles at you I get it
I'm gonna go on a date like that we're just
like shooting fireworks what oh my God Dave I
am Eduardo owner of Salsa Salsa Restaurant across
the mall this is definitely the villain right yeah
and I am going to need 200 of your best golf guys
decorated with the Mexican flag it looks something
like this yeah that's my future body right
there I'm going to assume that is Benjamin Brett
oh we've looked straight into your
future buddy and you are no good that
oh hell yes get it
hahaha oh why did they do a spin-off
in this world whoa he died in the most
natural way possible riding a shark
yeah oh my God this guy's awesome
volcano oh my God yes oh my goodness they never
found the body oh no all that was ever retrieved
this is freaking wild it escalated that guy
it's a great shot yeah oh cool like zoom
in yeah there's way better like framing
and lighting too like the lighting in
these shots is crazy I guess there's
more like style yeah behind the way
they frame it she gets spreads [Music]
trades others everywhere
huh let's try this one more time but the things a
bit less like a zombie okay she kisses my bubbles
this is so sad you need to
find a woman for your children
oh no the aliens are back
oh take off your goggles oh
what is that oh there are no booby trunks
what have you Unleashed ah
oh just a sweet little rooster don't be fooled
don't be fooled they'll claw
your eyes out some guard dogs
alien reference
[Music] whoa all right Wild
foreign [Music]
but hey maybe you can find
something with these x-ray goggles
if you were a spy Tara you would
behave exactly like this person
I would behave like wild yeah yeah
that adds up if someone were to ask me like who
do you know that is like agent
wild straight up without pausing
ah what is this sofa probably delicious
though can you hear me post that
I love that stop it's so dangerous
[Music] oh these minions need a
driving lesson oh yeah bro oh yeah
[Music] sign of a villain
oh my God I love me I love me so
much wait until the end to see if
I like this one more or not but so
far it is cooler yes I agree [Music]
stack of money for ice cream amazing why does
this guy want the minions I don't know [Music]
the Zen crew would have a hard time doing stop
oh
[Laughter] that's great girls Lucy Lucy
girls hello hi oh my god oh the mom fantasy
oh she likes the daddy side Tara
[Music]
just stroke that ego [Music]
oh my God margot's fallen in love too oh hey
whoa cool glasses I'm Antonio oh
is it the son of him yes because
the Z there's a z on his shirt welcome eagle
it's about time you showed up Mr gruel okay
I think you need to move around wow
this looks interesting what is it
hold on I'm picking up something behind that
wall oh yeah this wig will transform you from
ugly to irresistible don't get distracted
too late [Music] did he grab the wig yeah
[Music]
dream is to one day oh my God
you're so complicated complicated
that's great so good to see you again oh I see
you have already met my father oh that's why
I gave it all up Brew discovered traces of the
serum at Eagle Hair Club sure but it's not please
I like this new world that they have here a
lot the direct Mission objective I'm not as
clear of a fan of anything yeah I'm a little
bit lost yeah I'm like am I a little if I just
a little deprived or I am on the same page yeah
but I like dealing with the fatherly qualities
of him learning to be a yeah not be overly
Sheltering about the whole thing looks amazing
I want to go to there what
is the father of the minions
so we have like two villains
oh God [Music] oh my God that's right
irresistible hair I mean there's just some
look like a serial killer yeah
he looks insane and so does she
hi no sure just a sec no don't catch
it no no I'm so sad for her right now
oh good she can't see Gru oh will
she recognize him with his hair yeah
well in no time that's offensive is this woman
voiced by one of the people who plays the kids
are you wearing a wig no I'm gonna rip that
thing off your head and show everyone what a bird
she is intense
nice
he's been shot with a mild moose tranquilizer
[Music] she no lag oh she's just uh
look oh oh see see
oh my goodness [Music]
I like how they're not villains
this time around but they still
do cruel things to people yeah this
is their way about a romantic night
surprisingly it was just between
you and me you look much better bald
see you tomorrow smart to keep
the childlike eyes and I really
love the idea of him having a love
interest yeah it works really well
watching how it's affecting his emotions so
much it's great he's happy he's finding love
oh he's going to like yoga in the Park good
for him you know it's it's about these movies
like the gimmick of like the thievery the
villainy or the spy stuff is the appeal to
people but it's like the most fun the stuff I
love the most is always like this stuff right
the softer stuff and everything I agree
it's empty but we found traces of the PX4
one said a minute he's our man so somehow in
spite of your incompetence we solved this one
plant plant get your Miss off of me now you're
all free to go back to business and it looks
like agent Wilde will be transferred into our
Australian branch no I wanted to give you this
your lipstick taser yeah it's just a Memento
you're gonna remember me forever bye grew
oh it's look out the environment she says
Vine it's all right it's darker immediately
no guru don't go back to who you were don't
succumb to The Dark Knight of the soul group
oh would you like
uh no uh ah for real this time to
be yourself man oh come on that
was a real number I know it wasn't a
555 yeah what's that about should we
call it later did it have all the numbers
maybe it was one letter one number missing
oh my goodness [Music]
what is he doing oh my God [Music]
oh my God oh my God that is my favorite [Laughter]
also how have like Mark and Steve not been like
where are all the other minions like how has no
one been like where are the other ones you can
distinguish them no no he's always hanging out
with Mark and Steve and John and these guys
have cooler names the guys who are stolen
oh no they're you're gonna
turn into a giant purple minion
[Music]
yikes there are no rules Come on
they're starting man [Applause]
[Music]
this kid is so hands on oh my God
sticking up on him so much [Laughter]
this is a great visual motif foreign
sequels go this is a really great we are survivors
there's much more to us than meets the eye enjoy
the party this makes me want Mexican food oh
so where did he just run to it makes me want
authentic Mexican food too yeah Del Taco
Del Taco has better tacos than Taco Bell
because they have more it has more stuff in
it not everybody yell at me in the comments
the secret lair you are so
wrong about the Taco Bell
they tastes so much better I don't even
need it anymore I love both but Dental
tacos tacos are like bigger and they have
more they have more cheese on top oh no
not the guacamole hat oh so sad [Music] you are
gonna die somebody didn't take music theory oh
nice oh would you like some peanuts or pretzels
all of it my Ultimate Fantasy that is a good joke
she sees group everywhere she goes I
grew up
I would not want to travel with these guys
I love that Action Hero thing if they just
do this that means I go faster [Music]
evil magnet [Music]
where's his tattoo of the Mexico flag right yeah
it's time we shall Groove he was working for him
job opportunity absolutely oh that's why nefario
is kidnapping the minions I had to borrow some of
your minions but it was foreign because that's
horrible I want him to go back and not be weird
geez oh wow
and here's the best part I got
great visual gags in this movie
[Music] now he has to die anyone tries to stop
them [Music] together together you must choose Gru
I'm not so convinced
oh no now evil minion is gonna go ruin the
party we need to go home now where is Marvel
ous what is she heartbroken he's dancing
with someone else right now hey wrong
oh yeah
poor Mario yes nice he could
really go to jail for that have you
have you yes I take you somewhere around
here you two are close no oh I don't know
oh no put it together Lucy why did you say
we're close did he say that he never mentioned
that you were both working for the active
villain Nick uh-oh well nefario he knows
you're working for the AV Hill hey he's got
your partner thank you nefario both movies
you thought he was going to be bad but then he
ends up doing the right thing he's doing good
they kind of look like more advanced
stages of that one pet that Guru has
don't they oh yeah his rat terrier mixed with
a porcupine I got what a creepy POV I did yeah
oh yep
oh God this makes me dizzy there's like
some semi horror touches in this episode
yeah movie I don't see any [Music] oh
but Agnes could just like maybe disarm
him because she disarms the doggy
she'll be like David is that you
no the minions come out figure
out how to revert it back oh yeah
[Music]
oh that quick [Music] what what the
minions already had a serum antidote
okay
finally put this horrible jelly to some good
use oh wow before then you put it in all the
salsa right it's like a Shelly like I don't
know the gel you make it look salsa okay don't
be stupid minions like just eat this also they
all turn back but like if the guy doesn't know
you're using it an antidote serum he just
thinks you're feeding them okay that was
my idea get out it was dumb but for a moment
in time we are not watching Despicable Me 3D
masala
[Music]
that like twitching effect they got
don't get caught up in this man uh oh
God [Music]
ferocious little monster how are they
gonna they seem so much more formidable
as little villains than helpers they're
actually like a large quantities are scary
oh
you just get to spray them oh
nice oh hell yeah all right nice
oh what a fun arcade game that's awesome
yes
oh was that wrong no they're doing a great job
this is literally an arcadence yes it is ever this
is it see is my spirit animal I think you're not
supposed to say that anymore but she has my spirit
cool oh oh yes oh yes [Music] oh my God
look at that 3D it's coming right at me
he's over El Macho now where is Lucy
is that how much I like super strength
[Music]
Macho thing huh [Music] one push of this button
and I send that rocket straight into
the same volcano where I faked my dad
nice tally ho now oh no a macho Macho
Man are they gonna play that song now
dude he did not pick this through
dude nothing distro [Music] okay
Agnes scream you guys don't have more jelly
oh the lipstick taser yeah
[Music]
nice wow did that really solve the
problem now go get some jelly off
of the wall and shove it in his mouth
oh he still has some left no [Music]
farts gun actually got to be used
against a villain nice don't worry I will
oh no no chicken wants his revenge
oh boy there they go [Music]
with what Society does to chickens this chicken
deserves to live no all right yeah good good good
no absolutely you guys are not eating that shark
you put him back in the ocean we may not get out
of this alive so I need to ask you a question
the do it crew if I asked you out on the day
oh [Music] okay there goes that volcano
they make this disaster look so pretty
in the background no no no okay good
oh yeah no there's just way more texture to
it everything wow doesn't that look so pretty
oh yeah the other minions oh they're
still that's a great callback [Music]
they married wow that's so many dates
[Music]
it's such a such a simple joke
with them it works it works
and his nose is huge yeah hey that
curls at the wedding mom [Music]
I like to make some toast oh
[Music]
Lucy is beyond compared oh that's really sweet
wow I am see I I uh you didn't even get a wedding
outfit nefario his old date came to his wedding
yeah yeah I pointed that out earlier you did pay
attention this is why lo siento I heard you say
something but it was at the wedding I didn't hear
the name you remember her name no okay it lives
there were two directors this time around
uh well last time there were stuff during the
credits so we should now to see maybe there is
sawing its way in from the 3D
it's coming right at me [Music]
Cinematic Universe love it wow
uh oh I don't like 3D most of the time
why does it make you feel sick it just
doesn't even just it makes the screen look
darker and it doesn't really come at you
and then you get stuff like this like this which
is like where I'm like well I don't have any of
the effect desired effect it's going for yeah
oh you know what I like better than the 3D is
like the four matte whatever it's called when they
spray this stuff in the air and your seat vibrates
I might come down with that we could do that at
Creed and I could punch you in the boxing match
all of Greg's dreams coming true
just punching me in the face
hahaha
oh hair and fur
[Music]
these little freaks freaks adorable
the English best bee
oh no oh a boom blaster
[Music]
I do like the way this is
escalated it's pretty funny
minions
I mean that was pretty good I'm trying you just
you can't we got to do a whole review I like this
oh I cannot do it I'm trying I can do it you
have to do a whole no oh it was not too bad
we have to do a full review flight this
pretty good right everyone sold everyone
should annoyed the audience and try just
talk like that so they can't understand
we are saying I thought the movie it
was uh fun and brighter colors and
I liked it I don't sound like the woman
had my laundry really they're dry cleaners
oh he gets his suit done I'm gonna
hide my one suit he had to add in
that he's so important he has to wear
suits and he wears them so much he has
to get them clean when you're in
your 30s it's good to have a suit
when you're in your 30s these are Hot Tips by
Gregory Alba number one when you hit your 30s
get a suit get a suit and if you can get a second
wow it's too much listen I liked this movie and I
didn't like it as much as the first because the
first one uh the first one had more heart like
the first one movie cry at the end I really love
the speech that Agnes finally gives it she worked
on and then she finally gets to give it to her now
new mom but there wasn't enough of a relationship
built up between them for me to like really really
care I was surprised that they didn't towards the
end show just a quick Montage of dates but also
her being in the household with the girls because
I think even if it was like an extra minute
it would have made me feel more during Agnes's
speech if I had seen some clips of her getting to
know the kids in a cute moment where they're like
they're kind of shy but she's reading them books
now and like you know what I mean that was the
thing that popped in my head when she was given
that speech because I thought it was so stinking
adorable and I was like oh how could they have
actually made me cry during that moment when I
uh and I'm like oh as if we if we saw more of
the relationship that maybe would that would
have made it too long of a movie possibly but
um I still thought it was a lot of fun and I'm
glad nefario always comes back and has their back
yeah always always man yeah always the repeat beat
right there yeah you know I I like the world a lot
in this movie and I think it Direction Wise It's
Slicker it everything pops a lot more it's more
vibrant they actually have a lot of great Style
with their moving shots because I I remember
with the last movie like as I love the story
of the last movie and I remember saying like the
in surprisingly shot really simple like there's a
simple way of like capturing everything even with
the animation there's there's a Simplicity to it
and here they take that Simplicity but they add
on more to it and they they do a lot more with the
visual gags a lot of the way with the editing as
well with the reveals it there there was so much
more visually that I thought was aesthetically
more pleasing and then overall too for a part two
it's a pretty solid sequel It's really fun and the
evolution of Gru with you know first one is him
overcoming that sometimes you know Define love
you've got to overcome some of your parental
troubles yes right yes right yeah right men yeah
so you stop treating women like crap get over your
mom problems or wherever you saw your dad treat
their mom and then maybe you could find love
inside the same thing with women yeah or if your
mom was a jerk like you you know go to therapy for
that that's what I mean you gotta overcome those
things yeah so I actually like the transgression
of in the first movie it's him getting over some
of those parental troubles and then this allows
him to open the door to finding love finding a
woman who is not like his mom who can support him
you know who likes him yes bald head and his big
nose who accepts him for who he is it's good so
there's thematically I really like that a lot even
psychologically because it's really they do have a
psychological element with Gru overcoming
childhood traumas right they didn't have
now that you say that they didn't have any
callbacks as I thought they would in the first
movie they did multiple callbacks remember with
his like Mom when he was growing up or whatever
in the first movie they only did it that one time
where he was a kid in the yard and yeah that maybe
could have bened benefited this movie if they
had just showed it a couple more times like they
played with it in the first of him having like
an afraid moment before he even asks her like
I mean it could have even been a funny callback
of like he's on the rocket and being like he's
gonna ask her but there's a he has a moment where
we go into his head when he was a kid and he was
rejected I think I would have liked seeing that
yeah I would have liked it too I do think that
this movie is certainly creative and it's there
are a lot of inventive ways they did a lot of the
the entire execution there's a lot of event of
things on screen I do think the actual story is
a little bit more by the numbers for this genre
of what it is of like there was something that
was more unique I thought with the first movie and
I'm not just even talking about the introduction
of the world it's the the way the story plays
out with like this ridiculous thing of trying to
steal the moon and then you know finding the love
with the daughters and there's a unique tale of a
guy who uses these children and ends up being
like no I actually love you it's it's a much
more unique story for sure and it's all it's
weirder but it's I thought more touching and
then here it's a little bit more straightforward
yeah yeah like they follow the tropes of like what
we would see in an anti-villain like um whatever
we're gonna fight him down we gotta figure it out
like Yeah The Love Story too yeah well I liked it
I thought it was charming and I like I think Lucy
and Gru are uh there's they're really adorable
and I think uh imagine I wonder if Kristen Wiig
and Steve Carell were in the same booth together
recording because they do have great chemistry
um and other things they've worked on too yeah
yeah I agree yeah I also am still very concerned
about was that Mexican tattoo of the flag was that
so it wasn't a tattoo it was like it was drawn on
and then it just came off because I'm like that is
weird continuity that I was thinking about so much
that when they he finally admitted that he was the
villain and there was that big magnet that I was
like he's gonna come out and be like and this is
my evil brother who was distracting you with the
tattoo on it yeah so I'm like where did that go
that that was that was honestly that bugged me
for a minute I understand and I think his necklace
moved a little bit because the reason I said yeah
that's his son because he had a z on his shirt
because his thing had an M it's for M for Macho
but in some shots in the beginning it looked like
it was rotated to a z that's so that's why I said
that okay I also another thing I I like the sorry
what's the name of that girl who was into the sun
into the sun the girl who was
in who's into the villain's son
oh Margot Margot yeah I like the inclusion of
that story I don't feel like there was much of
a wrap up or a lesson really learn others it just
ended with her being like boys suck when it was
when it was one of their many B stories you're
right about that because that's what probably
led us well for sure leading us to going like
he might be the real villain and he's gonna
get to Margot and the kids and then it's gonna
blow up where they have to go save the kids or
something yeah but that just ended up being kind
of a a non-fulfilling Beast story of like yeah
this kid's a jerk because his dad's a jerk too
I know there was like in the middle of all the
cacophony of stuff at the same time I feel like
that did lend its open that could have opened a
door for some kind of emotional beat for Drew to
have yeah and some of those emotional beats with
the children were sort of missing here so that's I
actually get where you're coming from when it came
to that speech at the end yeah because there
wasn't much of the bonding that we saw and it
was just like oh they just want a mom instead
of seeing the relationship form of Lucy which
would have I think behooved the movie to and I
think both these movies are at their best yeah
when they're doing that stuff yes they are the
things maybe it's I don't know maybe for the kids
I don't know I don't know what the kids think
it's like maybe the kids like those the other
spy stuff more and and we as adults like the more
emotional stuff more like if it's standing reason
but imagine now that I'm thinking in my head it
would have been a perfect spot where Margo is sat
at Salsa and salsa but Margo uh sorry uh what's
the love interest name Lucy yeah Lucy but Lucy
shows up and is able to give her a talk about like
not like a full-on attack about boys but gives her
some sort of sentiment some sort of like sure yeah
you know what like you're right she like picks her
up and then Margo's like ah forget about it uh
maybe not totally but she teaches her something
and maybe we have a moment where Lucy teaches
yeah maybe one of the girls a little something
that they take that they haven't that you kind of
just cannot get from their dad yeah from a male
figure right that would have been really nice and
taken what 20 seconds with each kid if there was
a way to add it in there so yeah I agree I feel
like we're missing that but I also don't think if
they added it in that it would be a boring thing
for the kids to watch because I'm like the only
reason they got to Despicable Me too is because
one was freaking great you know I mean I still
think though the you know sequel to Despicable
Me could have easily just been as I've heard some
people not really praise some of the other ones
that much okay mind we'll see how they are yeah
um but I still feel like for a follow-up it's
it's really hard to do a follow-up to these kind
of movies they usually are just repetitive or they
get more childish and here I thought they at least
they really made a concerted effort to enhance
I think some people maybe like this one more I
actually and I saw comments of people saying like
vector's the best villain in the franchise oh I
personally preferred this yeah over over Vector
yeah vector vector I didn't we weren't the biggest
fans of actor yeah I didn't like dislike him just
didn't really leave it in person was like yeah it
was whatever and then here there's more of an
I feel like I'm gonna remember this one more
I think so too like his it's like he has more of
a larger broader character and maybe it was like
because we also weren't only introduced to
him as a villain right off the bat he had
he was just a regular person with a regular
like oh get me these cupcakes and join us
at this party and here's my kid and blah blah
blah versus with Vector we didn't really have
that we knew right away it was just like he's a
bad guy but we had to figure it out with Macho
macho man yeah interesting setting how most of
this was just at a mall it's really interesting
guys there there is like some Easter egg thing
when that you've our very first seeing them all
when you look up there is a Disney like d in
there and I'm like this is DreamWorks right
or it's elimination it's unit illumination
but anyway and then it was never there again
but I swear to you if you go and you look and
it's the little Disney like maybe saying hi
to him I don't know odd you know yeah it's a
whole thing anyway I mean I liked it [Music]
I'll give it like a 6.5 because I didn't get
the emotions out and the first one really did
that with me yeah um I I probably I'm actually
I really really admired it's so funny usually
in these situations on this channel I'm usually
the one a little bit lower than everyone else
but I'm actually I'd probably be like seven
yeah probably like a 7.5 because I thought
the directing and the cinematography and the
animation they really amp that up they really
in a way that just kept me kept my eyes glued to
the screen was because of that yeah I thought they
just they added so much personality and flourish
to that that that was weirdly the thing that was
kind of missing for me from the first movie
and and I thought they really brought that
here so just due to that like I'd still give
the first one like an 8.5 yeah oh me too for
sure because of the story yeah exactly yeah we're
here I would be like I I would get point I got to
give it points for the seven point like for
what they did because yeah I I do think that
um they introduced a neat World here with the
anti-villain league but they didn't really explore
it they were kind of doing a lot in this movie
there was a little it became a little it became
a little convoluted to me yeah I was like we're
both unclear about what the mission is what is the
exact objective here like they're trying to locate
the guy with the magnet right but I feel like have
we lost sight of that yeah but they think the
guy the the wrestler I forget his name uh Macho
Macho my God that's such an easy name the guy with
the magnet right is that what we're getting at uh
I think I get it but I feel like I'm
also not 100 sure yeah uh but nah man
overall I still want to see Despicable Me
uh whatever and then we'll see how it goes
shout out today proper I'm gonna watch you
do it I'm gonna watch you do it it's me
Tara and this is great and we were watching
Despicable Me 2 and we hope that you like
tell us if you want us to watch three we
love you goodbye illumination banana foreign